la parole est à Madame Murielle Jourda
rapporteur pour le Sénat de la
commission mixte paritaire pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutesè s'il vous
plaît allez-y madame la rapporteur merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre mes chers
collègues nous sommes ici effectivement
pour examiner les conclusion de la
commission mixte paritaire qui s'est
tenue aujourd'hui et hier sur le texte
de loi relatif à à
l'immigration la particularité de cette
commission mixte paritaire a été vous
l'avez tous saisi que d'habitude nous
travaillons sur deux textes celui du
Sénat et celui de l'Assemblée nationale
mais que en réalité nous n'avions qu'un
texte comme document de travail qui
était celui qui émanit du Sénat tandis
que celui de l'Assemblée nationale
n'avait pas été adopté c'est dans ces
circonstances par particulière qui me
semble-t-il impliquait que nous partions
comme base de travail du texte du Sénat
qui avait seul reçu l'onction
démocratique si je puux dire et une
onction assez large puisque je vous
rappelle que à 210 voix ce texte avait
été adopté c'est dans ces circonstances
particulières que nous avons débattu
dans le cadre de cette commission mixte
paritaire vous n'arez pas un grand
effort à faire pour comprendre quel est
le texte qui est issu de cette
commission mixte paritaire si ce n'est
un effort de mémoire puisque en réalité
il s'agit dans sa quasi intégralité
texte que nous avions approuvé au
Sénat nous avons maintenu l'architecture
de notre texte qui comprenait je le
rappelle un titre totalement nouveau sur
la maîtrise des entrées de l'immigration
dans notre territoire qui comprenait un
volet sur l'intégration qui comprenait
un volet sur l'éloignement puis et j'y
passe rapidement
deux séries de dispositions plus
technique l'une sur l'accueil des
demandeurs d'asile et l'autre sur les
procédures judiciaires c'était surtout
la première architecture qui nous
intéressait c'est-à-dire le titre sur
l'entrée et nous avons globalement
conservé ce que je peux estimêtre un
acquis un acquis du Sénat d'abord le
débat au Parlement avec une fixation de
quotas ensuite un affermissement des
procédures sur différents titres le
regroupement familial le titre étranger
malade mais également le titre étudiant
avec un un meilleur contrôle nous avions
aussi obtenu me semble-t-il une
amélioration sur l'aide médicale d'État
sur ce point nous avons acquis de madame
la Première ministre par un courrier
écrit envoyé à président Larcher le fait
que ce débat reprendrait à la lumière
aussi du rapport evvin stéphanini
rapport qui n'était pas inintéressant il
faut le dire dans les mois qui viennent
pour que nous puissions assurer un
meilleur contrôle de l'aide médicale
d'État et je prends je reprends sur ce
point les propos de madame la Première
ministre qui ont été écrits nous avions
donc
maintenu cet aspect qui est une
meilleure maîtrise de l'entrée sur notre
territoire par les étrangers et il me
semble que c'est un point extrêmement
important en tout cas nous le soulevons
avec Monsieur Philippe boncarer
corapporteur à chaque fois depuis qu ans
que nous avons traité le budget sur
l'immigration le deuxième point est
celui sur l'intégration et c'est un
point également important où il est
acquis me semble-t-il désormais qu'une
meilleure acquisition de la langue
française sera demandée à ceux qui
veulent vivre durablement en France dans
le d'une carte de séjour plurannuelle
mais également à ceux qui veulent venir
dans le cadre d'un regroupement familial
qui devront avoir aussi un niveau de
langue conséquent un examen civique est
également demandé qui permettra à ceux
qui veulent vivre chez nous et bien de
mieux comprendre quel est notre pays et
donc de mieux s'y intégrer et de mieux
s'y adapter on leur demandera aussi par
un contrat de respecter les principes de
la République les étrangers qui viennent
en France respectent tout simplement la
France on parl la langue et on
connaissent l'histoire et l'esprit
civique cela me semble nécessaire
l'intégration par le travail avait été
abordée nous avons longuement discuté de
ce point l'article 3 l'article 4 bis je
n'y reviens que pour vous dire que c'est
l'article 4 bis qui a été conservé pas
de prime à la fraude nous aurons donc
une régularisation qui se fera dans le
cadre d'une admission exceptionnelle au
séjour l'état conserve la maîtrise de la
politique migratoire et enfin ce volet
éloignement dont je vous ai parlé a été
totalement maintenu avec une
facilitation de l'éloignement finalement
de ceux qui causent des troubles à
l'ordre publ sur le territoire français
et en cela je pense que nous serons tous
d'accord enfin a été ajouté un titre
entier sur les outresmèes au Sénat nous
avons je crois un intérêt particulier
pour les outresmères nous l'avons
maintenu et nous avons dans le cadre de
cette CNT ajouter ajouter ce titre voilà
mes chers collègues ce que nous avons
fait sommairement car le temps ne me
permet pas de vous en dire plus sIIT que
je crois que par ce texte nous nous
attaquons à un problème qui est
essentiel pour nos compatriotes
nous le faisons d'une façon qui me
paraît extrêmement raisonnable mais qui
se veut efficace et qui j'espère sera
efficace si les conclusions cette
commission mixte paritaire sont adoptées
et c'est pourquoi dans la mesure où il
s'agit peu ou prou du texte que nous
avons précédemment voté je demande à
tous ceux qui l'avaient voté nous étions
210 à voter à nouveau les conclusions de
cette commission mixte paritaire je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci la parole est à présent à Monsieur
Gérald Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur
et des
outresmers monsieur le Président
Monsieur Madame la Ministre cher Sabrina
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois madame monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs pour le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outresb que je suis
après plus d'un an de discussion autour
d'un texte important et s'il avait été
discret je crois qu'il ne l'ai plus
après diverses discussions
parlementaires nous arrivons au but et
j'espère que votre assemblée comme celle
de l'Assemblée nationale le votera pour
pouvoir protéger les Français mieux
intégrer les étrangers simplifier la vie
administrative mais aussi il faut le
dire mais ici il faut le dire améliorer
des dispositions qui n'étaient pas prévu
dans le texte initiale du gouvernement
le texte du Sénat n'est pas le texte qui
remplace le texte du Gouvernement mais
qui le
complète sur 27
articles sur 27 articles un seul a été
retiré sur 27 articles initiaux du
projet du gouvernement un seul a été
retiré celui l'article 4 qui prévoyait
que les de demandeurs d'asile avant 6
mois sur le arrivée sur le sol national
pouvaient travailler tous les autres ont
été maintenus la plupart dans leur
intégralité parfois avec des
modifications mineures d'autresfis avec
des modification plus substantielle mais
dont l'esprit est resté le gouvernement
le gouvernement tenait et je crois la
majorité de l'Assemblée nationale avec
lui si je vais saluer le groupe de
François patria et de Claude maluret qui
nous ont soutenu dans cette action
tenait à l'équilibre de son
texte premier équilibre de ce texte
était évidemment l'intégration des
personnes étrangères beaucoup de
dispositions autour de la langue
notamment l'examen de français
obligatoire pour les titres pluriannuels
des dispositions autour du travail et je
voudrais dire ici que si le Sénat le
vote je crois qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup
de doute si l'Assemblée nationale le
vote il y aura donc pour la première
fois il y aura donc il y aura donc pour
la première fois dans l'histoire de la
République dans la loi une mesure L
iniative de
régularisation qui comme l'a souhaité le
gouvernement coupe le lien entre
employeur et employés pour pouvoir
connaître cette régularisation et
touchera des milliers de personnes
d'après le gouvernement entre 7 à 10000
personnes supplémentaires qui dans les
métiers attention mérite de sortir de
l'hypocrisie dans laquelle nous les
plongeons collectivement depuis temps de
gouvernement pour connaître évidemment
le monde normal classique quand on paye
des cotisations quand on paye des impôts
il est normal de dev voir reconnaître en
effet un titre de séjour sur le un titre
de séjour sur le sol de la République et
je m'étonne que la gauche ne le voit pas
sans doute sans doute regrettant de ne
l' pas fait de Pasir fait elle-même
chers
collègues deuxème sujet deè équilibre du
texte du Gouvernement c'était évidemment
un lien très fort qu'il y avait entre
d'un côté le fait qu'il fallait être à
l'écoute de l'intégration et plus
exigeant d'un C un point de vue et de
l'autre plus dur contre la délinquance
étrangère et les criminels étrangers de
ce point de vue je crois que le travail
parlementaire qu'on a eu notamment avec
le Sénat mais aussi la CMP a permis
d'améliorer les dispositifs du
gouvernement mais qui pour la première
fois depuis 25 ans reviennent sur les
protection qu'on appelait jadis la fin
de la double peine et permettre enfin de
pouvoir expulser les délinquants
étrangers du sol national ou de leur
retirer leur titre de séjour parce
qu'ils adhèrent à une idéologie radicale
ou parce qu'ils sont contre les droits
de la République en même temps si j'ose
dire que les délinquants étrangers qui
doivent être combattu pour la première
fois dans la loi de la République et
après 50 ans de demande d'à peu près
tout le monde associatif et de tous les
partis politiques de gauche mais qui ne
le font jamais lorsqu'ils sont en
responsabilité pour la première fois
nous allons nous allons pour la première
fois nous allons interdire le placement
des enfants des mineurs dans les centres
de rétention administrative dans tous
les lieux de rétention administrative et
on le devra au gouvernement on le devra
au président de la République et à ceux
qui le voteront dans quelques instants
ce sera une grande avancée qui devrait
me semble-t-il attirer l'attention de
quelques-uns sur le troisème sujet qui
est un sujet monsieur le président de la
commission des lois et je le regrette
très important sans doute le plus
important mais qui n'a pas fait floresse
dans les débats médiatiques ni
parlementaires la simplification de
procédures administrativ inspiré
directement de votre rapport monsieur le
Président lui-même inspiré du rapport de
Monsieur Stal au Conseil d'État je pense
que nous armons profondément notre
justice administrative dans la
simplification 12 procédures passées à 3
là encore deux titres très importants
des dizaines d'articles un droit
complètement changé pour l'instant ça
n'a pas fait la une des journaux
j'espère que ça le fera demain mais je
pense que c'est un vux pieux 3è et 4e
pardon et dernier sujet le gouvernement
a donc pris acte d'abord du travail qu'a
fait le Sénat et je veux ici remercier
l'ensemble des sénateurs de tous les
groupes puisque nous avons pris des
amendements de tous les groupes de tous
les groupes et bien sûr ceux de la
majorité sénatorielle et de la majorité
présidentielle nous n'étions pas
d'accord sur tout nous étions dit mais
je voudrais dire que je crois que vous
avez vu un gouvernement qui était à
l'écoute des dispositions souhaitées et
d'ailleurs des partis ou des groupes de
la majorité parlementaire à l'Assemblée
qui vous ont soutenu puisque monsieur
patria monsieur maluré ont voté
favorablement à ce texte je veux faire
remarquer d'ailleurs qu'alors que le
texte du Sénat est à une version plus
dure puisque nous avons modifié 15
articles en CMP et que nous avons retiré
la me que nous avons retiré la fin de
l'hébergement d'urgence on va l'appeler
comme ça pour la rapidité du discours
alors que nous avons mis évidemment dans
la loi les métiers en tention alors que
nous avons mis jusqu'à 18 ans la fin
déplacement des mineurs en centre de
rétention administratif alors que nous
avons prévu une exception pour la
caution pour les éant étrangers
particulièrement méritants bien sûr
alors que nous avons largement rabotté
une mesure sur les prestations sociales
on en reparlera si vous le souhaitez
passant de 5 ans à 3 mois ou de 5 ans à
zéro pour la plupart de ceux qui
travaillent je voudrais remarquer ici
que les deux sénateurs du rassemblée
nationale ont voté contre ce texte et
permettez-moi de m'attirer l'attention
sur un point
précis voilà donc voilà donc un drôle de
moment parlementaire où un texte qui est
version on va dire plus dure plus dure
que ce que propose le gouvernement qui
est plus Durre que la version qui est
présentée aujourd'hui chacun doit faire
un pas vers l'autre et je pense que
c'est le principe d'un accord
parlementaire quand un texte est dur
réputé comme dur les deux sén du
rassemblement national ne vote pas bon
tout augmente tout augmente vous avez
raison monsieur le Président
rillot les sénateurs du rassemblement
national ne votent pas ce texte
considérant qu'il y a des
régularisations considérant qu'il ne
répond à rien considérant qu'il ne sert
à rien attaquant les LR attaquant les
centristes attaquant la majorité
parlementaire et puis quand Madame Le
Pen voit le jour se lever comme le coque
de Chantecler là elle se dit tiens quel
petit coup politique je peux faire ça
dupe personne grâce à l'action du Sénat
grâce à l'action du Sénat et du
gouvernement nous aurons un texte pour
protéger les
Français alors il est vrai comme le
disait le le général le Gaul sur
l'essentiel nous
pouvons non mais je sais que vous l'avez
combattu toute votre vie c'est pas la
peine maintenant qu'il est maintenant
qu'il n'est plus là de vous reprocher le
général de Gaulle mais sur l'essentiel
sur l'essentiel nous pouvons nous
retrouver et je veux dire au sénateurs
de l'ANUP
je veux dire au sénateur de la s'il vous
plaît mes chers
collègues je veux dire au sénateur de
l'ANUP c'est pas non plus c'est pas non
plus une insulte c'est pas non plus une
insulteè s'il vous plat chaque groupe
aura l'occasion de s'exprimer laissz le
ministre s'exprimer que les par qui ad
à
son le vote du rassembl national sur la
Moon de Roger empêchant bien évidemment
empêchant évidemment le débat
parlementaire classique mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs le président de
la République la première ministre et le
gouvernement a présenté un texte
courageux et chacun le constate un texte
difficile il a dit dès le début qu' ne
procéderait pas à l'adoption de
l'article 49 aléa 3 afin de des débats
et il a tenu
parole il a dit dès le début qu'il
chercherait le plus possible dans des
conditions qu'il n'it pas tout à fait
imaginer comme celle-là bien évidemment
un accord avec tous ceux qui voulaient
travailler pour le bien et la protection
des
Français non mais vous pouvez parler du
rassemblé national le RN ici a voté
contre aucune disposition n'a été
négocier avec eux ils sont contre les
quotasè ils sont contre les quotas ils
sont contre les régularisations ils sont
contre la fin des mineurs dans les
centres de rétention administratif ils
sont contre les passeports talent ils
sont contre les mesures sur
l'hébergement ils sont contre les
mesures qui concernent les
étudiants ils sont contre l'intégralité
des dispositions puisqu'ils ont connu à
trois exceptions près des votes contre
en commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs de l'anupes faut regardeer les
choses et soyez bourouurs il y a un
accord politique qui ne satisfait
personne un accord qui ne satisfait
personne totalement mais qui permet à
chacune et à chacun de se retrouver sur
l'essentiel la protection des Français
je ne serereit pas le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui pour vous faire plaisir
fera la politique du pire et désarmera
les policiers les gendarmes et les
magistrats dans ce contexte monsieur le
président le gouvernement qui n'a pas
utilisé le 493 qui a laissé le débat
venir jusqu'à la fin qui a
renvoyé qui a renvoyé qui a renvoyé le
texte du Sénat puisque l'assemblée n'a
pas voulu en discuter malgré le travail
très important fait en commission des
lois de l'Assemblée nationale en
commission mix paritaire a tout fait je
crois qu'on peut le dire avec le groupe
centriste avec le groupe DLR avec le
groupe de Monsieur maluré group monieur
patri pour trouver le meilleur accord
possible bien sûr bien sûr
il y a des questions encore autour de ce
texte chacun c'est je veux le dire ici
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs ce'est pas faire un jour au
Sénat et nous en avons parlé librement
bien sûr dans cet hémicycle les débats
en font foi des mesures sont
manifestement et clairement contraire à
la
Constitution le travail du Conseil
constitutionnel fera son office mais la
politique ce n'est pas être juriste
avant les juristes la politique est
d'élaborer des normes et de constater si
sont ou pas d'après nous conformes et
oui des questions se posent sur un
certain nombre de dispositions qui
pourrait être soit non conventionnel
soit peu constitutionnel mais laissons
le Conseil constitutionnel faire son
affaire je veux dire ici qu'en tant que
ministreintérieur et des autres maires
j'appliquerai bien évidemment non
seulement la lettre de la loi qui sera
promulguée par le Président de la
République et par le Conseil
constitutionnel mais également l'esprit
avec lequel nous avons travaillé tous
ensemble mesdames et messieurs monsieurs
les sénateurs il est évident qu'être
ministre de l'Intérieur et présenter un
texte alors qu'on a une majorité
relative dans des conditions médiatiques
politiques que nous connaissons n'est
pas la chose la plus facile mais mais je
suis certain qu'ici et là les Français
dans leur immense majorité voient que
nous avons pris nos responsabilités et
venant par deux fois venant par deux
fois de deux familles immigrées qui sont
arrivés sur le sol français étant élu
moi-même dans un territoire que
qualifier de gauche où Monsieur
Mélenchon et laanupè font 34 % au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle dans ma commune je
constate que je n'ai aucune leçon à
recevoir de brevet de morale elle ne se
fait pas à saint-jamain de près elle se
fait dans l'hémicycle pour l'Assemblée
nationale et dans le
Sénat
merci
merci mes chers collègues je rappelle
qu'en application de l'article 42 alinéa
12 du règlement le Sénat statut par un
seul vote sur l'ensemble du texte nous
passons aux explications de vote des
groupes en raison d'un orateur par
groupe la parole est à présent à
Monsieur Michel massé pour le groupe
RDSE pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la ministre mesdames madames et
monsieurs les rapporteurs monsieur
président la commission des lois mes
chers
collègues de questions qui requierrent
votre attention
aujourd'hui d'abord celle de la méthode
d'élaboration de ce texte au cours de la
navette ensuite celle du fond et de la
position de notre Parlement au sujet de
l'immigration en premier lieu concernant
la méthode le groupe RDSE
s'interroge nous aimons rappeler à cette
tribune notre attachement au débat
parlementair comme essence de nos
régimes démocratiqu et
républicain privé nos hémicycles de
délibération d'échang voir de
controversse c'est s'exposé au risque de
dévoyer et pervertir l'expression même
de la volonté
générale au débat c'est faire un pas
vers l'arbitraire vers un monde de
décision si symptomatique ancien et qui
avait justifié différentes étapes de
notre de notre
histoire il a donc été décidé que seul
le Sénat
examinerait disposition par
disposition chacun des articles du
projet de
loi le groupe RDSE avait dit sa position
à l'issue de l'examen
nous étions majoritairement contre la
rédaction
sénatoriale mais nous acceptons les
règles du jeu
démocratique à l'Assemblée nationale une
majorité était contre saura-t-on
pourquoi au motif de la suppression de
laame ou bien de la mise en place d'un
titre de séjour méti en tenstion pas de
débat pas de
réponse nous voilà aujourd'hui avec un
nouveau texte débattu à H clos et
négocié un lapse de temps restreint
contraint la réunion de la CMP aura
réussi à durer plus longtemps que
l'examen devant la Chambre
basse j'imagine que c inédite dans notre
Histoire parlementaire il demeure que
comme jeune sénateur je suis aussi
étonné que préoccupé en découvrant cette
méthode la Constitution le permet soit
les rouages du Parlement charisme
rationalisé prouve leur efficacité
jusqu'à des situations démocratiquement
excusez-moi absurdes nous gardons donc
la liberté de ne pas nous satisfaire
d'un tel cheminement
nousurons finalement qu'à peine quelques
minutes pour découvrir le détail de la
nouvelle version du projet autant dire
que notre connaissance tient pour
beaucoup aux articles de presse ou
autres là encore c'est
insatisfaisant malgré ça puisqueun texte
nous est présenté il me faut tout de
même aborder le
fond celui initial du gouvernement avait
plutôt tendance à nous satisfaire
monsieur le
ministre moins de personnes en revanche
la tournure de nos débats au Sénat avait
fait pencher une majorité des membres
notre groupe à vootter contre et les
autres s'étant abstenu nous étions
unanimement contre pardon la suppression
de laame elle ne figure pas dans le
nouveau texte tant mieux il s'agissait
pour nous d'une ligne
infranchissable il y avait aussi la
question des titres de séjour pour les
travailleurs sans papier la version
sénatoriale semble l'avoir emporté sur
le dispositif initial proposé par le
gouvernement nous le regrettons les
articles 3 et 4 constituaient à nos yeux
une avancée utile et efficace certes à
perfire à par faaire en début persiste
également dans le texte l'instauration
de côas migratoirees le durcissement des
règles du regroupement familial le
durcissement des règles relative à
l'immigration étudiante le
conditionnement du bénéfice de certaines
prestations sociales non contributive à
une durée minimale de séjour régulier le
rétablissement du délou du délit pardon
du séjour irrégulier ou encore la
restriction du droit du sol pour l'accès
à la nationalité bon bien sûr il n'y a
pas que cela le texte comprend également
des mesures attendues en matière
d'application des
otf je pense aussi à la réforme du
contentieux des étrangers ou bien au
durcissement des sanctions pénales en
cas d'exploitation des migrants cela
étant malgré ces
dispositions la majorité des membres de
notre groupe persistera à voter contre
ce
texte je vous remercie la parole est
présent à notre collègue Olivier Beitz
pour le groupe du Rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes indépendants
pour 5
minutes merci Monsieur le le Président
Madame et monsieurs les ministres
monsieur le Président de la Commission
madame et monsieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues le projet de loi
contrôler l'immigration et améliorer
l'intégration voulu par le gouvernement
répondit à l'exigence d'adaptation de
notre droit aux nouvelles réalités que
notre pays connaît dans le domaine
migratoire la situation demande en effet
aujourd'hui de mieux réguler les flux de
mieux protéger les Français contre les
délinquants étrangers et de mieux
intégrer grâce à l'affirmation de nos
valeurs au travail et à l'usage de notre
langue des étrangers et en vocation à
rester sur le territoire national au
sein de notre assemblée saisie en
première lecture les débats ont été
riches et constructifs ils ont permis
l'adop sur d'un texte que la majorité du
groupe RDPI a voté validant ainsi une
démarche de de coconstruction qui devait
se poursuivre dans le cadre de la
navette parlementaire car oui je l'avais
exprimé à cette tribune certaines
dispositions contenues dans le texte
voté par notre assemblée ne nous
convenait pas et notre vote positif ne
valait pas quitus il en était ainsi tout
particulièrement pour la suppression de
l'Ame le travail législatif était
néanmoins bien lancé pour doter notre
pays de la législation dont il a
besoin malheureusement une coalition
aussi étrange qu'étéroclite a vu le jour
à l'Assemblée nationale pour mettre en
difficulté le gouvernement et finalement
provoquer une brusque accélération des
échanges qui auraiit dû en toute
hypothèse avoir lieu entre nos deux
chambres notre groupe a abordé cette
commission mixte paritaire en ayant
toujours la même priorité à l'esprit
aboutir à un texte équilibré qui soit
une réponse efficace aux besoins du pays
et aux attentes des Français un accord
était impératif pas seulement pour le
gouvernement et la majorité
présidentielle pas seulement pour l'ELR
mais pour le pays tout entier ces
échanges nous les avons eu sous le
regard attentif des français puisque 67
% d'entre eux se sont déclarés
favorables à ce texte sur
l'immigration cependant chacun
s'accordait pour dire que certaines des
dispositions votées par le Sénat comme
certaines dispositions votées par la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nécessité d'être
réécrite s'agissant de l'Ame nous avons
tenu compte à la CMP des conclusions
sans équivoque du rapport rédigé par
msieurs Stéphan et Evin ce rapport
estime que l'aide médicale d'État est
utile et maîtrisée c'est ce qui nous a
conduit à revenir sur la souppression de
laame proposée par le texte du Sénat
compte tenu de l'engagement de notre
première ministre d'engager dans les
meilleurs délais une réforme forme
concernant les prestations sociales le
texte du Sénat conditionnait toutes les
aides non contributibles à une résidence
de 5 ans sur le territoire national
elles ont été réduites les les les
délais à la fois ont été réduits et les
périmètres également les périmètres des
aides concernées s'agissant de la
nationalité nous avons supprimé cinq
articles qui à nos yeux étaient
problématique restera par contre et nous
l'assumons la déchéance de nationalité
pour les binationaux condamn pour
homicide sur personne dépositaire de
l'autorité publique pour l'hébergement
d'urgence là encore le texte du CTA
n'était pas vraiment applicable en
l'état il faut bien le dire car il
risquait de mettre à la rue plus de
150000 personnes du jour au lendemain
pour l'obtention du titre de séjour
étranger malade enfin nous nous en
resterons à la rédaction de la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale à nos yeux plus juste et plus
équilibré compte tenu des débats
constructifs et du texte auquel nous
avons réussi à aboutir en commission
mixte paritaire sous l'gide de nos
rapporteurs sous l'égide des deux
présidents de des commissions des des
lois de nos assemblées notre groupe
votera dans sa majorité pour le projet
de loi présenter les conclusion de la
CMP je vous
remercie merci la parole est à présent
au président Patrick canner pour le
groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madamees et
monsieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues depuis hier nous avons eu avec
mes collègues Marie-Pierre de la
Gonterie et Corina rassiguin la charge
et l'honneur de porter dans cette CMP
certes les propositions de notre groupe
mais surtout la défense d'une certaine
idée des valeurs de notre pays dans son
histoire la France s'est construite avec
l'apport et la contribution des
populations étrangères parfois même au
prix de leur sang et c'est aussi
Monsieur le Ministre un fils d'immigré
qui vous le dit ce soir aujourd'hui
encore sans les travailleurs étrangers
les hôpitaux où vous vous faites soigner
les aides à domiciles qui prennent soin
de vos parents les maisons que vous
faites construire le supermarché où vous
faites vos cours et bien sans les
immigrés rien de tout cela ne pourrait
fonctionner et vous le
savez
c'est c'est à eux que je pense ce soir à
chacune de ces personnes qui ont fait le
choix souvent contraint de s'installer
sur notre sol diffonder leur famille d'y
construire une nouvelle vie car il
s'agit bien de cela de vie humaine avant
tout qui mérite respect et
considération quand le 11 janvier
dernier j'ai reçu au Sénat mieur
dermanin et duop ceci avait vanté
équilibre de leur projet de loi il
s'agissait alors de mieux contrôler
l'immigration mais aussi de faciliter
l'intégration des étrangers dans notre
pays ce soir je le constate amèrement
cette promesse était un leure pour dire
les choses clairement ce texte sur
lequel nous sommes amenés à nous
prononcer aujourd'hui est un texte de
police des étrangers dans la quête d'un
électorat perdu le gouvernement et la
droite ont choisi de se fondre dans la
rhtorique que seule l'extrême droite
défendait jusqu'àors la France au
français
je vous le dis comme je le pense la
violence de ce texte nous heurte ce
texte est une honte d'heure en heure de
recul en recul de marchandage en
marchandage la droite a entraîné une
majorité présidentielle complaisante
dans un ravin populiste sous l'œil
gourmand de l'extrême droite en toute
logique en toute
logique cette extrême droite votera ce
projet de loi ce projet de loi elle
aurait même pu l'écrire cette extrême
droite Rance et haineuse qui se frotte
les mains en contemplant ce spectacle
cette marée brune qui fait sauter toutes
les digues les unes après les autres mes
chers
collègues mes chers collègues je suis
inquiet pour mon pays pour son avenir
que reste-t-il de nos valeurs de nos
idéaux de la France pays des droits de
l'homme par deux fois Emmanuel Macron
est arrivé au pouvoir car nous car nous
étions nombreux à espérer qu'il fasse
barrage à l'extrême droite aujourd le
même Emmanuel Macron amène les idées
d'extrême droite au pouvoir je
m'adresse je m'adresse aux
parlementaires qui de bonne foi ont cru
en même temps du président de la
République ouvrez les yeux en 2027
allez-vous assumer d'avoir donné corps
aux pires excès de l'extrême droite
assumerez-vous d'avoir gravé la
préférence nationale dans le marbre de
la loi assumerez-vous d'avoir privé les
étrangers en situation régulière ainsi
que leurs enfants de moyens de
subsistance pendant plusieurs années
assumerez-vous d'avoir mis à terre les
principes de la nationalité
assumerez-vous d'avoir imposé aux
étudiants des conditions inatteignables
pour rejoindre nos universités
assumerez-vous d'avoir réduit les
travailleurs dans les métiers en
tenstion à de simples variable
d'ajustement assumerez-vous de n'avoir
pas fermé la porte à la remise en cause
de l'aide médicale d'État les
dispositions que vous avez voté depuis
hier soir sont une insulte à nos
lumières comment d'ailleurs nos
collègues centristes comment nos
collègues centristes depuis la première
lecture au Sénat peuvent-ils accepter de
prêter la main à une telle dérive
extrémiste à rebour de leur propre
histoire non mes chers collègues un
étranger n'est pas appissance un danger
pour notre civilisation notre mode de
vie notre activité économique vous vous
êtes laissé submerger par des fantasmes
d'un notre temps non seulement vous
renoncez à nos valeurs fondatrices mais
avec ce texte vous ajoutez du désordre
au désordre le droit des étrangers sans
pile des enfants non accompagnés sont à
la rue des situations d'étrangers sont
examiné de manière partielle et partiale
les otf sont délivré n'importe comment
elles ne sont pas appliqué mes chers
collègues ce 1912 marque l'entrée de la
droite et du centre dans la majorité
présidentielle au risque de leur propre
disparition ce 19 décembre sonne la
rupture de la digue défendue pendant de
nombreuses années par la droite
française contre l'extrême droite ce 19
décembre le Front républicain a fait
long feu vous avez inventé la
cohabitation d'opportunités la coalition
sans contrat la collision la collision
du renoncement mais rappelez-vous les
Français préféreront toujours l'original
à la copie vous êtes vainqueur peut-être
ce soir mais êtes-vous vraiment les
bénéficiaires de cette victoire vous
avez choisi de tourner le dos à ce beau
concept écrit par l'un des vôtres mieux
vaut perdre une élection que perdre son
âme je termine rassurez-vous un vant
mauvais souffle sur notre territoire
pour notre part en gardant la nuide nous
voterons contre ce projet de loi
immigration la parole est à présent au
président François Noël buffet pour le
groupe les républicains pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutessur président monsieur le
ministre madame le rapporteur monsieur
le rapporteur chers
collègues les donneurs de leçon de ce
soir qu'il soit de gauche ou d'extrême
droite ont oublié qu'il y a quelques
années ils avaient mis en commun leur
conivance sous la présidence du
président mitteron pour faire émerger le
Front national ils l'ont
oublié
vous vousz perdu la
mémoire et pourtant ce soir vous osez
encore nous donner des leçons moi je
voudrais simplement dire à cette
tribune que au début des débats sur ce
texte sur l'immigration le gouvernement
est venu avec son texte il faisait 27
articles que la commission des lois l'
travaillé la majorité sénatoriale l'a
travaillé en compagnie d'autres
collègues qui se sont
naturellement attachés à faire
progresser ce texte et nous avons
aujourd'hui un texte d'un peu plus de 80
articles ce n'est pas la quantité qui
fait la qualité mais c'est d'abord la
stratégie qu'il est important c'est
d'abord la stratégie qu'il est important
de rappeler nous assumons totalement les
choix qui ont été faits ils ne viennent
pas de nulle part ils viennent d'un
travail de longue haleine qui a été
effectué dans cette maison qui a été
effectué par notre
mouvement c'est le fruit de rapports
issus d'ailleurs de la commission des
lois c'est le fruit de propositions qui
sont venu
d'autres horizons d'autres collègues
bien évidemment c'est le fruit aussi
c'est le fruit aussi d'un travail
acharné d'une vision quelle était cette
vision c'est la cohérence d'abord de
maîtriser l'immigration irrégulière de
ne pas
rester finalement passif par rapport à
ce à ce qui se passe c'est le choix de
lutter fermement contre l'immigration
irrégulière en considérant que la
tolérance devait être de zéro ni plus ni
moins c'est la tolérance l'objectif
aussi de protéger contrairement à ce
qu'on imagine la procédure d'asile
régulièrement détournée et je dis bien
protéger la procédure d'asile qui est en
train de vivre de sombres moments parce
qu'elle est utilisée par les réseaux
mafieux à son détriment et au détriment
de ceux qui méritent la protection au
détriment de ceux qui méritent la
protection et puis c'est bien sûr la
simplification des procédures la
simplification des procédures
contentieuses qui dans ce texte vont
permettre enfin à nos magistrats à notre
administration de fonctionner
normalement bien sûr que nous avons
travaillé sur d'autres sujets on n parle
plus aujourd'hui on se concentre de
quelques points mais la réalité
rappelez-vous c'est tout le travail sur
le débat annuel sur les sujets
d'immigration c'est tout le respect des
valeurs de la République qui ont été
réintroduites dans ce texte c'est tout
le sujet sur l'apprentissage de la
langue vous ne parlez que de ce qui ne
marche pas moi je parle de ce qui est
positif et nous parlons de ce qui est
positif en faveur évidemment de
l'intégration qui doit être le sujet
absolument partagé alors la CMP a une
particularité elle a une spécificité
c'est que le texte issu de nos rangs ici
au Sénat largement voté n'a pas trouvé
finalement de contradictur en face de
lui à l'Assemblée nationale puisqu'il
n'y a pas eu de texte et vous avez
d'ailleurs allègrement mé vos
voix à ceux que vous combattez
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas hésité vous
n'avez pas hésité une seconde pas une
seconde alors les leçons de morale ça
suffit alors je voudis vous dire que
nous n'avons pas eu à l'Assemblée
nationale monur la parole est au
président buffet et à lui seul nous nous
sommes retrouvés à l'Assemblée nationale
avec une case vide pas de texte et le
texte qui fait référence c'est le nôtre
il a fait il a été le fruit d'un travail
et de discussion avec nos contradicteurs
de l'Assemblée nationale avec des
rapporteurs monsieur le ministre madame
la ministre que vous aviez à l'assem
nationale un travail de fond approfondi
on a discuté on a fait évoluer les
choses on a tenu compte de leur demande
et on est arrivé un accord au bout de
ces discussions certes elles ont été
longues et alors que nous auraitons
reproché si nous avions bâlé les
opération elles ont été longues elles
ont été menées correctement et nous
aboutissons à ce texte ce soir je
voudrais vous dire puisque le temps est
effectivement assez bref qu'il faudrait
rappeler deux trois choses en
particulier une peut-être de 3 mais une
parce que le temps mais compté
euh dans cette
maison le rassemblement national n'a pas
voté le texte nous avons entendu pendant
des semaines et des semaines qu'il était
le texte le plus abominable du monde
qu'il était même pas suffisamment dur et
ce soir on vient essayer de faire un
holdup sur ce texte mais ce n'est pas
votre texte ce n'est pas vos idées ce
sont les nôtres et uniquement les nôtres
et c'est donc le texte ce soir de la
commission mixte paritaire qui résulte
d'un accord avec la majorité de
l'Assemblée nationale et qui est le
résultat j'en termine monsieur le
Président qui est le résultat d'un
travail de longue haleine je le redis
qui a été là je voudrais remercier les
collègues du groupe LR les collègues du
groupe centriste et tous ceux qui sont
associés à ce travail et c'est merci à
vous merci monsieur le Président
buffet
mes chers collègues la parole est à
présent à Monsieur Christopher zourk
pour les sénateurs ne figurant sur la
liste d'aucun groupe pour 3 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur monsieur
le ministre chers collègues nous y voilà
donc nous le savions tous avant
d'engager ce long chemin parlementaire
nos compatriotes attendent désespérément
des mesures réelles pour arrêter la
submersion migratoire qui assaille notre
pays les effets destructeurs de
l'immigration dérégulé sur notre pays ne
sont plus à démontrer ce texte devait
ainsi répondre à ce défi fondamental
pour notre pays pour notre pour nos
compatriotes l'absence de prise de
conscience réelle du problème migratoire
depuis 50 ans a entraîné une situation
insupportable alors que nous accueillons
500000 entrées légales et illégales par
an la France s'ouvre d'une immigration
profondément inadapté aux besoins de
notre économie et au vœux de nos
compatriotes loin d'être cette
immigration de travail qui pourvoirait
les soi-disant emplois abandonnés par
les Français le phénomène migratoire
actuel est une charge que nous ne
pouvons plus assumer ni d'un point de
vue économique ni d'un point de vue
politique social culturel sécuritaire
démographique et j'iraai même jusqu'à
dire moral cette loi accouché au force
s'est passé par les fourches codines de
l'hystérisation médiatique et
parlementaire était une belle promesse
exence culturelle limitation de l'accès
inconditionnel aux prestations sociales
non contributives simplification du du
contentieux des étrangers création d'un
délis de séjour irrégulier réforme de
l'accès à la nationalité ces objectifs
le rassemblement national les partage
mais surtout nos compatriotes les
demande alors ce texte n'est pas parfait
il reste bien en dessa de ce que nous
souhaitons mais il a au moins permis de
remettre au centre du débat la priorité
nationale que nous appelons de nos vœux
depuis quelques jours la gauche montre
au créneau pour dénoncer la PO priorité
nationale la qualifiant de mesure
raciste inhumaine antirépublicaine avant
d'être porté par le FN et le RN la
priorité nation était une mesure
défendue par la gauche contre le
capitalisme qui souhaitait constituer
son armée de réserve exploitable à Mercy
et à bas prix le Front populaire
lui-même pris des décrets pour limiter
l'apport de main d'œuvre étrangère et
lutter contre l'immigration illégale et
de Salang grro à marché cette priorité
fut défendue mes chers collègues la
priorité nationale n'est pas une
exclusion c'est faire le choix des
nôtres avant les autres c'est l'idée que
nos compatriotes d'où qu'ils viennent
sont au cœur de nos préoccupations et
sont la priorité de nos combats et nous
sont personne salir ce qui devrait être
le sacerdoce de tout élu de notre
République Monsieur le Ministre j'ai
bien conscience que vous essayez de
faire croire que vous avez encore la
main et que ce texte est bien le vôtre
mais aujourd'hui la représentation
nationale l'emporte sur le gouvernement
après des mois de mépris à trou joué on
perd parfois cela servira peut-être de
leçon à un exécutif qui a cru pouvoir
malmener le pouvoir législatif quoi
qu'il en soit aujourd'hui fidèle à nos
engagement de défendre nos compatriotes
de soutenir tous les projets qui iraient
dans le sens de leurs intérêts d'où
qu'ils viennent nous voterons ce texte
de concerts avec nos collègues à
l'Assemblée nationale pour le reste nous
payons pas deot seul une réforme
constitutionnel et un référendum sur
l'immigration répondront réellement aux
aspirations des Français et nous
continuerons de le demander je vous
remerci la parole est à présent Monsieur
Louis Vogel pour le groupe les
indépendants pour 5
minutes mes chers collègues s'il vous
plaît
monsieural
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre madame et
Messieurs les rapporteurs monsieur le
président de la commission des lois mes
chers
collègues au même titre que le reste du
continent notre pays fait face
aujourd'hui à un afflux migratoire
majeur nos partenaires européens ont
pris diverses mesures pour y faire
face la Finlande a fermé sa frontière
russe le Danemark a envisagé de renvoyer
ses migrants au
Rwanda il faut dire que la Turquie la
Biélorussie la Russie n'hésit pas à
employer les flus migratoires comme arme
géopolitique contre
l'Europe nos concitoyens sont 71 % à
considérer que l'immigration est trop
importante en
France dans ces conditions nous devions
légiférer
il fallait mettre un terme au
détournement manifeste de notre droit
comme l'a rappelé le président de la
commission des lois mettre en uvre une
immigration choisie sur la base de quota
et reconduire à la frontière ceux qui
n'ont pas leur place dans notre pays
nous nous réjouissons groupe des
indépendants que la commission mixte
paritaire soit parvenue à un
accord l'équilibre général du texte issu
du Sénat a été
respecté il oriente notre pays vers une
immigration
choisie le Parlement a fait ce choix en
précisant d'abord ce qu'il voulait un
flux d'immigration mieux contrôlé
notamment à travers l'instauration de
quota le texte sur lequel nous allons
voter rappelle également un principe
fondamental le communautarisme n'a pas
sa place dans notre pays la finalité de
l'immigration est l'intégration
comme cela a été rappelé par Madame la
rapporteur les deux clés les deux clés
d'une intégration réussie sont la
maîtrise de la langue de la langue
française et le
travail la régularisation des étrangers
qui sont employés dans les métiers en
tension traduit notre attachement à la
valeur travail il est important de
sortir ces personnes de toute
vulnérabilité tout en évitant tout appel
d'air cette mesure ne doit pas nous
empêcher de réfléchir aux causes
profondes de la pénurie de main d'œuvre
dans certains secteurs qui est évidente
et d'y apporter des solutions le texte
de la CMP dit également ce que nous ne
voulons pas les étrangers ne respectant
pas nos lois nos droits nos devoirs
essentiels et nos valeurs ne doivent pas
pouvoir rester dans notre pays de trop
nombreuses dispositions empêchai leur
réloignement tandis que les des délits
et des crimes continuaient d'être commis
par ces mêmes personnes nos concitoyens
ne peuvent plus l'accepter et il était
grand temps d'y
remédier la maîtrise des flux
migratoires ne pourra toutefois être
tout à fait efficace qu'à la condition
d'être accompagné de règles européennes
efficaces la liberté de circulation au
sein de l'espace Schengen implique
nécessairement un contrôle strict aux
frontières de
l'Union l'ensemble des citoyens de
l'Union européenne nourrissent de fortes
attentes dans l'obtique de l'adoption
prochaine du pacte asile et
migration l'Union européenne doit elle
aussi faire preuve de son efficacité et
ne pas prêter le flan aux critiques
comme tous les Européens nos concitoyens
ne peuvent plus accepter une immigration
subie la politique doit relever le défi
migratoire avec justice et fermeté sans
attendre le nouveau paquet législatif
européen le groupe Les Indépendants
votera en faveur de l'adoption de ce
texte merci la parole est à présent à
notre collègue Philippe boncarer pour le
groupe de l'Union centriste pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre madame la ministre monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
mes chers collègues intervenant à la
tribune pour le groupe centriste et non
pas comme corapporteur il m'est permis
de commencer par des remerciements des
remerciements à Madame Jourda mon
corapporteur au président buffet à nos
administrateurs et à tous ceux qui dans
les différents groupes et en particulier
les groupes de la majorité sénatoriale
nous ont accompagné pendant un temps
long que cela soit bien sûr en séance
que ça soit dans les travaux
préparatoires ou pour la période en CMP
un grand remerciement chers collègues
pour votre
[Applaudissements]
investissement vous dire ensuite que le
texte qui vous est soumis exprime une
fermeté que pour nous il exprime nous le
résumerions ainsi une autorité
régalienne forte dans le respect de
l'État de droit c'est donc un texte
ferme ceci vous a été ex imé c'est aussi
un texte c'est moins évoqué qui marque
un retour du Parlement dans la
définition de la politique migratoire
c'est le sens de l'article
1a c'est aussi un texte et qui marque
une volonté de compromis de la me à
l'article 4 bis ou au travail
d'intégration par la niveau linguistique
euh nous avons démontré notre capacité à
trouver des compromis et à dégagé des
solutions je voulais ensuite vous dire
que c'est un texte qui exprime la
solidité de la majorité sénatoriale je
ne suis pas celui qui a vocation à
m'exprimer à ce titre mais quand même je
voulais vous dire chers collègues que le
travail qu' MT mené en commun nous a
permis de dégager un premier compromis
qui n'était pas acquis au sein de notre
majorité sénatoriale en particulier vous
l'avez tous en tête sur le 4AD bis nous
l'avons fait cela nous a permis
d'adopter ad un texte et que chacun
s'est approprié c'est assez remarquable
de voir comment toute la majorité c'est
finalement approprié le texte issu de
nos travaux et nous avons pu mener
ensemble et je vous en remercie monsieur
le Président retaillot un deuxième
compromis qui était pour le moins pas
évident avec la majorité présidentielle
c'est un exercice qui était difficile
mais que je crois qui a été réussi et
qui a été réussi au service d'un
parlement qui fonctionne parce que c'est
ça l'élément essentiel le Sénat par les
positions qu'il a adopté qu'il a porté
qu'il a réussi à construire a permis
d'éviter un vide
institutionnel quelle aurait été la
situation si nous n'avions pas pu voter
un texte si l'Assemblée nationale
n'avait pas pu voter un texte c'était
une situation qui mettait effectivement
en cause la stabilité de nos
institutions et ça je crois que nos
concit CEN ne l'aurit pas
[Applaudissements]
accepté vous avez fait ce que vous
deviez faire au service de l'intérêt
général je vrais terminer par le débat
politique puisque à l'évidence ce n'est
plus un sujet technique mais bien un
sujet politique et répondre aux
critiques qui ont été exprimé par la
gauche en vous disant que chacun sera
jugé sur ses idées et sur ses rés
nous vous avons observé chers collègues
pendant une semaine en séance avant et
après vous n'avez pas approuvé vous
n'avez pas approuvé une mesure qui
porterait orientation encadrement
régulation je ne sais trop quoi
concernant les flux migratoires et vous
n'avez pas manqué une mesure qui
pourrait quelque part
désarmer notre outil régalien dans la
gestion des flux migratoires et dans la
défense de nos frontières il nous est
quand même permis de vous dire que dans
un pays il y a l'obligation de lui
donner les moyens d'égresser sa
souveraineté et je terminerai par la
question et je terminerai par la
question du rassemblement national qui
obsède effectivement les esprits en vous
disant que les centristes sont les
adversaires politiques du rassemblement
nationalersèg nous le disons nous
l'exprimons la paille et la poutre vous
cherchez la paille dans nos regards
regardez la poutre dans le
votre notre sujet ce soir c'est orn les
peurs et les ses exploitations à nous
l'efficacité et la recherche de
solutions et j'en terminerai en vous
disant que ce qui fait aussi not
différence avec le RN c'est que nous
croyons à l'État de droit et que
l'autorité régalienne va pour nous avec
le respect de l'État de droit merci de
merci chers
collègues la parole est à notre collègue
gu benaroche pour le groupe écologist
solidarité et territoire pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madames messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues nous sommes
arrivés au bout du cheminement
constitutionnel ou anticonstitutionnel
d'ailleurs on verra de ce texte reste le
passage à l'Assemblée nationale tout à
l'heure à tout seigneur tout honneur ce
texte est une victoire de la majorité
sénatoriale qui a fait plier le
gouvernement et a fait adopter sans
texte dans les grandes lignes cela
marque donc
l'officialisation de son intégration
définitive à la majorité gouvernementale
LR et lrem sont des alliés non de
circonstances mais de
[Applaudissements]
fait depuis Le Vot du RDPI sur le texte
au Sénat d'ailleurs tout semblait dit
cette loi d'affichage est regrettable et
dangereuse nombre de ces mesures sont
totalement étrangères au texte initial
et tout l'aspect d'intégration a été
sacrifié pour une victoire politicienne
à la
pyus ce texte a échappé à ses auteurs et
ce depuis le mois de février monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur où notre
Assemblée a pu l'étudier en commission
c'est bien un texte dicté par la
majorité sénatoriale qui est sorti des
discussions de la CMP je dis discussion
mais les méthodes d'employés lors de
cette réunion n'avaent rien de dire
suspension immédiate suspension répétée
réunion de couloir réunion avec
l'exécutif à matigon à l'Élysée tant
plus que restraint entre la conclusion
de la CMP et sa discussion dans notre
assemblée comme au bon vieux temps
oserais-je dire des textes d'urgence
sanitaire sommes surtout arrivés au bout
de la logique présidentielle du quoi
qu'il en coûte un texte aussi éloigné de
ces premières annonces mais un texte un
texte puisqu'il fallait un texte c'était
la cantation du président de la
République l'enjeu est trop important
pour la nation pour faire de la
politique politicienne c'est le ministre
de l'Intérieur Gérald vermana qui le dit
sur cette loi je suis favorable à ce
qu'un compromis intelligent soit trouvé
au service de l'intérêt général c'est ce
qu'avait dit vendredi le président
Macron quôa d'immigration d'élit de
solidarité préférence nationale pour les
allocations familiales d'élit s jour
irrégulier majoration des frais
d'inscription universitaire caution pour
les étrangers pour les étudiants trer
hors Union Européenne restriction de
l'accès à la nationalité par le droit du
sol limitation du regroupement familial
et j'en passe et le gouvernement clame
un équilibre avec d'autres mesures
lesquelles la victoire idéologique du
rassemblement national est plus forte
chaque jour c'est par ces mot que Jordan
bardellaa a qualifié les résultats des
tractations de la CMP notre groupe le
constate et le déplore ce texte est pas
de trop celui qui a aussi le plus de
conséquences humaine et politique ce
n'est pas la peine de se cacher derrière
des mesures dites gentill l'aggravation
des peines pour les marchand de sommeil
quel étranger prendra le risque de
dénancer le raquette qu'il subissent
s'il risque l'expulsion les mesures
d'interdiction des bueurs dans lesécas
une demande répétée de notre groupes et
d'autres suite à une dizaine de
condamnations de notre pays par la CEDH
plus qu'une avancée à saluer c'est un
retour à l'état de droit normal trop
tardif quand à la mesure phare
d'équilibre la régularisation de droit
pour les travailleurs dans les métiers
en tenstion elle n'existe plus elle a
vite été oubliée comme le ministre du
Travail Olivier dsamp disparu au champ
d'honneur de cette loi cette
régularisation de droit et la pièce
manquante de l'intégration Prée par le
titre de ce texte comment ne pas vouloir
permettre à des personnes qui
travaillent qui veulent s'intégrer de
s'extirper de la peur permanente du
contrôle de l'éloignement d'un nouvel
exordre personne ne peut être
complètement intégré même après des
années avec cette peur permanente
intégré par le travail c'est aussi
régularisé par le travail et que dire du
discours culpabilisant demandant un
texte et un vent pour se donner les
moyens de protéger les Français outre
son aspect nosé Aban assimilant
l'immigration un danger dont il faut
protéger les Français c'est une fable
rien je dis rien dans ce texte ne permet
l'amélioration des ooctf auquel le
gouvernement a si attaché annonçant
arriver à 100 %
d'exécution rien dans la diminution des
droits et des protections ne constitue
non plus une plus grande garantie
d'exécution d'une mesure d'éloignement
vous le savez cette hypocrisie cache mal
votre vision de l'immigration une vision
de l'étranger dangereux calculateur et
profiteur la politisation au tranière de
la question migratoire est un piège qui
ne profite à personne ou alors à qui
cette collusion avec la droite pour
reprendre des idées et des slogans de la
droite extrême et et de l'extrême droite
est inédite et indigne nous sommes les
seuls à avoir pu imposer ce texte à
déclarer ricoti danscte notre groupe
dénonce tant les méthodes employés que
le fond de ce texte nous voterons contre
ce texte avec force et conviction et
nous appelons l'ensemble des
parlementaires du centre et de droite à
peser la réalité du texte final qui nous
est proposé avec leur conviction intime
et leur engagement politique comme
commence à le faire de nombreux
députésci
et de N
ministr la parole est à
[Musique]
présent à Monsieur Yann brossa pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste kanaki pour 5
minutes monsieur le monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je ne
m'étendrai pas sur les conditions pour
le moins chaotique dans lesquels nous
discutons de ce texte conditions
chaotique al alors même que la
commission mixte paritaire vient de
s'achever alors même que plusieurs
ministres du gouvernement annoncent
l'intention de démissionner alors même
que plusieurs députés de la majorité
annoncent qu'ils voteront contre ce
texte alors même monsieur le ministre
que vous nous dites vous-même que
plusieurs des mesures qui sont contenues
dans ce projet de loi sont contraires à
notre Constitution ce qui n'est pas rien
quand
même monsieur le ministre
souvenons-nous de ce que vous nous
disiez il y a quelques mois vous nous
disiez nous voulons être gentil avec les
gentils et méchant avec les méchants il
manquait manifestement une précision un
détail un codicile qui avait quand même
son importance c'est que au fond à vos
yeux aux yeux des républicains aux yeux
de l'extrême droite le seul fait d'être
étranger Vous range dans la catégorie
des méchants parce que c'est cela la
réalité parce que c'est cela la
réalité vous pouvez vous pouvez
protester mais sinon comment comprendre
comment comprendre qu'un texte qui nous
est présenté au départ comme un moyen de
lutter contre l'immigration irrégulière
qu'un texte qui nous est présenté comme
un moyen de lutter contre les
délinquants sans papier finit prangé en
situation
[Applaudissements]
régulière comment comprendre comment
justifier que dans ce texte qui est
censé lutter contre l'immigration
irrégulière Vous allez vous en prendre
aux allocations familiales à laap à
laallocation de rentrée scolaire
d'enfants y compris français qui ont
pour seul tort d'être né de parents
étrangers voilà la réalité de votre
texte vous nous avez vous nous avez au
départ vendu un texte
d'intégration un texte d'intégration
disiez-vous c'est tout c'est tout sauf
un texte d'intégration c'est un texte de
stigmatisation et d'exclusion c'est un
texte de discrimination et c'est un
texte surtout qui accroîtra la pauvreté
sur le territoire français parce que
privé d'allocation familiale des
familles privé de prestation sociale des
familles c'est accroître la précarité
dans un pays qui compte déjà excuser du
peu c'est aussi votre bilan 100 millions
de pauvres 4 millions de Français mal
logés 2 millions de Français qui
fréquentent l'aide alimentaire c'est à
croire que cela ne vous suffit pas et
vous allez encore aggraver cette
situation et dans ces conditions dans
ces conditions il n'est pas très
surprenant il n'y a que vous qui
paraissez surpris que l'extrême droite
vote avec vous sur ce texte que vous
vous retrouviez aujourd'hui main dans la
main dans une nouvelle majorité
Renaissance LR rassemblement national
voilà la conséquence des concessions que
vous avez faites depuis plusieurs
semaines à la droite et à l'extrême
droite alors dans ces conditions dans
ces conditions quels arguments vous
reste-t-il l'argument que vous répétez
matin midi et soir c'est ce que veulent
les Français curieusement cet argument
vous l'aviez oublié pendant le mouvement
des retraites alors même que vous avez
imposé au français un texte qu'il
rejetait par million dans les rues et en
se mettant en grève
et vous oubliez vous oubliez quand même
un peu vite vos propos lénifiants entre
les deux tours de l'élection
présidentielle lorsque le président de
la République Emmanuel Macron allait
mendier les voix des électeurs de gauche
au nom de la défense des valeurs de la
République pour faire barrage à
l'extrême droite et le résultat c'est
qu'on a élu Emmanuel Macron on n'a pas
voté pour l'extrême droite et on se
retrouve avec le programme de l'extrême
droite et avec la préférence nationale
dans la loi de la
République
alors il est bien évident il est bien
évident que chacune chacun dans ce
contexte- là doit mesurer la
responsabilité qui est la sienne la
question qui était posée la semaine
dernière c'était qui vote avec qui avec
cette fameuse motion de rejet à
l'Assemblée nationale aujourd'hui le
sujet ça n'est pas qui vote avec qui
c'est d'abord qui vote quoi et qui prend
la responsabilité notamment du côté des
macronistes de voter pour des mesures
qui vont dans le sens de ce que propos
au Front national dans les années 80 une
chose est sûre ne nous faites pas croire
que vous avez des principes ne nous
faites pas croire que vous avez des
valeurs ne nous faites pas croire que
vous avez une colonne vertébrale vous
n'avez que l'opportunisme pour guide et
nous voterons par conséquent contre ce
[Applaudissements]
texte mes chers collègues conformément à
l'article 42 ala 12 du règlement je vais
mettre au voix l'ensemble du projet de
loi dans la rédaction résultant du texte
élaboré par la commission mixte
paritaire je suis saisi de trois
demandes de scrutin publ émanant du
groupe les républicains du groupe
écologie solidarité territoire ainsi que
du groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain le scrutin est donc
ouvert
il est 20h11 nous sommes en direct sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat dans un
instant vous allez pouvoir suivre le
résultat de ce vote sur les conclusions
de la commission mixte paritaire qui
était réuni jusqu'à cet après-midi à
l'Assemblée nationale se députés 7
sénateurs qui sont parvenus à un accord
sur le projet de doit immigration
première étape donc qui va être sans
doute franchie sans peu de suspense dans
les prochaines secondes puisque le
droite de la droite et le centre devrai
voter ici au Sénat les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire le le plus
compliqué viendra ensuite he vers 20
21h30 avec l'examen de ces mêmes
conclusions de la CMP à l'Assemblée
nationale mais vous avez entendu à la
tribune les sénateurs de la droite et du
centre qui ont dit bien le fait qu'il
validait tout ce qui était sorti de la
commission mix paritaire de la CMP et
que effectivement maintenant et bien
sans problème ces sénateurs de la droite
et du centre pouvait voter les
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire il y a donc un scrutin public
qui va intervenir dans quelques secondes
vous allez pouvoir voir comme cela la
cartographie du vote dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat mais donc je vous le disais sans
en grande surprise les LR les centristes
vont voter pour la gauche va voter
contre mais la majorité étant ici à la
Chambre haute favorable à la droite et
le centre les conclusions de la
commission mix paritaire vont pouvoir
être adoptées dans quelques secondes
quelques minutes le temps que tout le
monde vote avec un un bulletin
électronique dans l'enceinte de la
chambre haute et depuis 19h vous avez pu
suivre les explications de vote et les
la discussion générale autour de ces
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire je vous le rappelle cette
commission mixte paritaire qui était
réunie depuis 17h hier à l'Assemblée
Nationale 7 député 7 sénateur et qui ont
réussi à trouver un accord dans
l'après-midi sur les conclusions à
apporter au projet de loi immigration et
un texte qui ressemble à s prendre à la
version du Sénat vous allez pouvoir
avoir la cartographie exacte du vote
c'est parti pour les résultats du
scrutin scrutin votant 34 exprimé
328 pour 214 contre 114 le Sénat a
adopté le projet de
loi mes chers collègues je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
21h45 pour la suite de l'examen du
projet de loi visant à renforcer la
lutte